[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is up fam it is Monday February 6th
it is Big Time fight week UFC 284
pay-per-view is going down this freaking
Saturday finally a big boy fight to kick
off the year baby UFC 284 in Australia
you got Makita volkanovski Yaya
Rodriguez Josh Emmett this badass Jack
Della Madonna is that you say it
Magdalena maddalena Randy Brown that's a
great fight that Jack kid is a beast
Jimmy crude Alonso menifeeled Jim
mccooten needs to win here Tyson Pedro
our boy uh Jamie Malarkey this thing is
so goddamn Australian you see me good
night for them I think we'll get into
that but uh UFC 284 is here pay-per-view
Big Boy Pay-per-view on ESPN and uh also
Big Boy show coming up we're doing a Joe
Rogan fight companion in Austin with the
original crew Brian Callan Eddie Bravo
The One and Only Joe Rogan and myself we
will be going live I think on Joe's
YouTube and then if you don't watch it
live it gets uploaded to Spotify so make
sure you check that out this Saturday uh
7 P.M Pacific time so it's at 9 00 uh
p.m uh central time yeah should be yeah
that's right that's right you already
checked out
um yeah so that's going down for all you
folks out there the original Crews
getting back together in Austin now I'm
getting Austin a little early because I
have a very special
food truck Diaries going down
um we'll announce the guests yet but a
very special one should be a fun one
um Casey and I are flying out there
early to shoot this bad boy where are we
doing that case
CM Smokehouse in Austin is where it's
going down so looking forward to that uh
your boys fresh off the road from
Springfield Missouri
uh listen fam doing stand-up comedy will
take you to places you never thought
you'd be in doing stand-up comedy I've
never even heard of Springfield Missouri
when I get there and uh
first of all there's I get to the hotel
there's dick swartson uh flipped me off
I thought I was graded so that's cool
um so uh the thing is is uh
I didn't know what to expect out of
Springfield Missouri and I gotta be
honest man that Blue Room comedy club
top five of all time I mean fantastic
room the Mandarin's great uh the crowds
were insane it was just a good time
great time me and Jay went down there we
didn't bring the whole thick boy crew
David Lucas didn't come just didn't come
Trey Stewart didn't come The Usual
Suspects they were busy on the road
doing their own thing so it's just me
and my brother so we used the local
Springfield Missouri Comics they were
great we had one guy named Willie he was
90 years old 90 years old from Bronx New
York he's been stand up for 40 years and
uh he comes with those fire one-liners
90 dude 90. Dirty Man Dirty Old Men but
very funny shout out to Willie dude if
you're hopefully if you are listening
this you're you're hearing aids turn up
Peak peek Peak peak hours right now so
you can hear me give me a shout out
Willie love you buddy
um yeah Springfield special placement
Springfield uh now they kept saying Brad
Pitt's from there Brad Pitt was born in
Oklahoma but he was raised in
Springfield so Brad Pitt you might see
him pop up from time to time in
Springfield Missouri
um it's about an hour outside of the
Ozarks you don't need to go on my page
June it's about an hour outside the
Ozarks
um and they're mainly known for well the
biggest the the owner of Bass Pro
Fishing uh is from there I think he's a
billionaire and he started the first
bass pro fishing out of there or like
the biggest one me and my brother's side
go the aquarium dude
you've been to Long Beach Aquarium it
shits on that
name would quit Sea World shit's on Sea
World I'm it's insane dude just to get
all through through just an aquarium
where they have alligators
sharks stingrays you can pet the
Stingrays just get through it you'll get
two hours if you take your time they
told me to expect four hours me and Jay
did 90 minutes because we you know
passed some of the stupid fish but um it
was nuts dude
nuts nuts and just says you love it it
just has
I mean entire it's multi-level one floor
just all fishing yeah it's all fishing
gear fishing boats hunting
to restaurants the restaurant they're
Hemingways yeah Steakhouse nuts nutsos
Dad one just level that was Presidents
fishing and I guess the owner of Bass
Pro uh shop was really close with the
bushes so they made a boat just for
George Bush uh George W bush so it's his
like presidential boat have it in there
there's a picture of just George Bush
and that rich ass billionaire just
murdering fish like
just doing the damn thing but
Springfield I will always go back to man
phenomenal Club ridiculous club man you
never know what to expect I've been in
some of those smaller cities man and the
clubs are tough
clubs are very tough sleepy towns you
know the the venues might be set up good
but it's just the audience you know it's
just a sleepy Town not this place man
the great great spot phenomenal spot
gotta be honest uh Naples you're up next
uh this weekend I'm in Austin next
weekend I'm in Naples Thursday Friday
Saturday Comedy Off The Hook I'll be
doing some fishing out there that's
February 16th through the 18th then
Bakersfield California one night only
that's a Thursday night February 23rd
things almost sold out Bakersfield let's
go not adding shows there I can't so you
get one night there now I'm one night in
Brea California March 3rd we had to
cancel the fourth because on the fourth
I have a fight campaign a very special
fight Japan you think I'm gonna miss Jon
Jones debut at heavyweight sorry Brea
but uh we had to push that one back so
there's just one show I'm sorry one
night two shows in Brea California Bray
improv March 3rd two shows so get you
some then we're in Oklahoma City Tacoma
the list goes on and on but Naples
you're up next February 16th through the
18th Comedy Off The Hook then
Bakersfield one night prayer one night
get you some uh make sure you tune into
the fight comparing with Joe Rogan Eddie
Bravo Brian Cowan myself on Rogan's
YouTube channel then we'll be fully
uploaded to a Spotify I'm excited for
that man Nothing Better
funnest show that I do is that fight
companion nothing freaking better uh but
I'm excited for the fights this weekend
but last weekend you got it right Jen I
was uh able to stream some of the fights
the UFC didn't stand for since I did
stand for and also for those hardcores I
did stay up how heartbroken were you
when Derrick Lewis got demolished and
like four minutes what was it three
minutes some [__] like that it was a
rough night for the hard course because
yeah three minutes it's a rough night
for the hard course because you know if
you're hardcore you you have a deep
sense of pride no pun intended in The
Pride Fighting Championship right the
pride Never Dies I think it died on
Saturday night finally the nails in the
coffin when Fedor goes away like that
that he's the last remaining Emperor and
you know
I don't agree listen
I like what Bellator did honoring the
greats I wish they would have done it
earlier I don't like that it was a kind
of somber because after Fedor loses he's
in there you know it's kind of tough to
watch it's like you know it was just I I
thought they could have done it
different I think they should have
honored them before the show started
before the main card started like you
bring all them out you open the
broadcast with that
go through the broadcast then Fedor has
because it's Fedor right it's Fedor so
he should have had his own thing even be
lost so it's just really primarily
focused on Fedor but it was kind of
weird it was like somber kind of
depressing type of thing and then also I
mean the UFC's no Dorsey down for doing
it Bellator not really but they did do
it here he shouldn't have been fighting
for title in his last fight his
retirement fight like give him a fight
that he can win have him find another
Legend at the same though you have to be
the same age but maybe the same miles on
the on the tires you know like Ryan
Bader what you think this is gonna go
down I mean there's always that you know
kind of man if he could just clip him or
it's Ryan Bader dude you know you beat
the [__] out it wasn't even a fight and
it's like that's his last time that's
not the way you show respect or tribute
to a legend let's look what they did to
Shogun look what they did to Frankie
Edgar like these guys that just get
starched I just don't agree with it
here's the thing yeah and Connor wants
to fight Michael Taylor Alex volkanoski
yeah we get it dude you've earned that
right but somewhere along the lines
management and then also whoever owns
those organizations go we get it this is
why you are a fader that's why you are
Connor that's why you are you know
Frankie Edgar you you think you can beat
these guys that the mind's still there
and the heart's still there the body's
not so what made Fedor special with his
that was his athleticism and his
explosiveness now when you're his age
was he 45 46 46 that's the first thing
to leave explosiveness athleticism first
thing you leave so if you take Fado's
athleticism you take how explosive he
was remember just pop off on guys or
slam guys or you take that away you
don't have a world beater you got a
legend who's gonna beat the [__] up
which is what's happening so it's tough
man now look he's coming off what two
wins he beat Rampage could he be tail
yeah yeah that's who we should be
fighting those are exactly the guys he
should be fighting but uh Ryan Peters no
punk dude so he beat Timothy Johnson in
Russia he'd be quitting Rampage Jackson
lost a Bader before I beat chelseonan
beat Frank Mayer lost to my boy matrione
uh Fabiano Madonna majority decision
most people think Madonna won that fight
you know
so you you know when he fights like the
Metreon the Rhine baiters he loses you
know but look Timothy Johnson Quinton
Chael Frank these other Legends you know
no shade on Timothy he's not a legend
but he should have his last fight should
have been a guy like Timothy Johnson or
Clinton Rampage or Chael sonen or Frank
mayor you know or he should have fought
like Josh Barnett
that'd been sick yeah I think Josh beats
him but he should have thought of Josh
Barnett another It's just tough to go
out on uh Ryan beta note and now it's
another feather and Ryan Bader's cap
he's undefeated but I think this is when
they say Pride Never Dies no it's over
unfortunately it's over Crow cop gave
him a sweet you know
kind of tribute post uh I mean the
history of those two but let's take a
little break as my Lord we have two
title fights this Saturday one freaking
epic night that Saturday at 9 00 p.m
Central Time 7 P.M Pacific time I'm
talking about UFC 284 Dana White's not
gonna promote it so I will this Saturday
Islam marketev is fighting keep his
title at 155 against the badass Alex
volkonovsky the 145 pound-for-pound
number one in the world he is hoping to
make history as the first Australian to
hold a title in two divisions all at
once join the MMA action with draftking
Sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the UFC new customers can bet
just five dollars and get 200 in bonus
bets instantly
as you're going to listen to this show
I'm going out on a limb on here you know
I always like the dogs but this is a
special type of dog you're talking about
the pound for pound number one fighter
in the world is a dog his size his
height his reach his skill set is an
advantage here it's not a disadvantage I
actually think the shorter limbs the the
the height it's gonna be tougher if my
chub to get him down I'm taking the dog
here I think Alex volkanovsky beats
makachev in a five round decision three
rounds to two it's gonna be a close
fight they do it again but I do think
Alex volkanovski gets it done this
Trucking Saturday night all right if the
excitement in the hot gun isn't enough
football fans don't forget to join the
big game we talk about the Super Ball in
Phoenix Arizona and it is happening this
Sunday at draftking Sportsbook you got
the Chiefs you got your Eagles I'm
taking the dog there too I think the
Chiefs are underdogs aren't they are
they plus one and a half either way I
like the Chiefs all right down download
the app now use code shop show new
customers can bet five dollars on UFC
284 and get 200 in bonus bets instantly
this Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook
with the code shop show schab show
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details UFC 284
I'm taking Alexander volkonovsky you're
welcome you know then Johnny Eblen I
told you guys he's top five in any
organization in the world that dude is a
Savage Savage
he would he would be a problem for
anybody in the UFC you know he's half
Korean I just found that out Johnny
Ebola yeah his name's Johnny Edwin he's
a half he didn't even look is he your
favorite fighter now oh we were stoked
we saw a Korean writing on his
background like why does he have Korean
writing on his back it's tattoos then
when we looked it up he's after in his
mom's green but his mom's full-blown
good yeah holy [__] I didn't know that
you would never expect to see with their
Korean mother American foreign
military thing right most likely yeah
that's usually how it happens oh wow
he's a University of Missouri guy God
Missouri has some think of Missouri I'm
not you know as much as I love
Springfield and it just so happens to
that I came from there it's one of my
favorite clubs of all time but thing and
he's not American top team everybody
says how much of a nightmare he used to
work with he's such a beast nightmare
not being difficult nightmare meaning
skill set tough like all the top guys
say he's a complete monster
um but thinking about out of Missouri
you know Ben aspirin
you got
um Woodley
um Michael Chandler
uh Milwaukee so you know you at a close
Milwaukee you got the Pettis Brothers
um you got uh Johnny eblin you know you
got some Savages that come out of that
wrestling room in Missouri dude Jesus
Christ
Jesus Christ good for him good for him
man so Johnny Edwin got the job done
Ryan Bader got the job done Brandon Ward
got the job done I think those are three
wrestlers right heavy wrestling
backgrounds uh Brandon Ward you had uh
Jean-Claude Van Damme jump in the
Octagon which is kind of awkward funny
moment of the night when Fedor gets in
there with all the Legends and uh he's
going around he gets the truck you know
truck to put on some weight so as
Rampage we did a food truck with Rampage
like that boys thick yeah you guys will
see that food truck he's one of my faves
but
um
Fedor gets in there he's like shaking
hands of the way then he gets to Chuck
and he's like oh my God grab his tummy
let me get the hell out of here
but just some Legends dude Legends doing
their thing it's cool that they honored
him UFC really doesn't do that you know
so it's cool that Bellator did they just
kind of fumbled the bag there doing at
the end when everyone's all sacked his
finger goes the ass whooped in two
minutes you know Lorenz Larkin probably
MVP of the night
Lorenz Larkin everybody else did did
what they were supposed to do Lorenz
Larkin The Way That Elbow people forget
Lorenz Larkin when he left the UFC
remember he was a top 10 in the UFC
leaves I don't think he's lost in five
years like he's
you know this is one of the problems
when you leave the UFC is his pictures
him shooting a gun uh go down okay
yeah go down for me
to the fight to his record
right there so he had a no contest
um but then that's the guy he just
starched so there you go that settles
that so yeah he hasn't lost since 2018.
he had a little rough start when he got
to Bellator lost to Douglas Lima for the
championship lost to Paul Daly
um but you look at what he's done when
he laughed you know he beat Neil magni
wrote off the sunset Neil Magnum that's
when Neil's doing the damn thing he beat
Jorge mazvidal
uh lost a split decision keep going down
uh beat uh pots and ebio who was that
time of savage that's five of the Night
Beat John Howard they're in a little bit
of a rough one but yeah the guy's a
[__] Savage beat Robbie Lawler in
2012 Robbie Lawler
Scotty light yep
I mean the guy hasn't lost since 2018
just flies into the radar this is part
of the problem like I'm all for guys
testing free agency but when you when
you leave the UFC
it might be a bigger bag I don't know
how it's going to work with compensation
sponsorships and now people are like
well the UFC can't have sponsorships
inside that gun I know but you have more
sponsors outside Dr outside of the UFC
outside of the Octagon like because
you're still in that mainstream the
biggest League you have more eyeballs
which means more followers all that [__]
so I'm worried even though like I'm
making so much more money I'm like to
fight you are I wonder how that works
outside of that
cage you know yeah but Lorenz Larkin is
just a Savage that's so underrated
something funny now these payouts are
hilarious yeah right they're hilarious
you know you guys know that fatal is not
fighting for a hundred thousand dollars
correct you know the guy who's pound for
pound top three heavyweight of all time
ain't fighting his last fight for a
hundred grand and Ryan Bader didn't make
150 Grand the belt was paying those boys
way more than that
but he's getting paid more than that the
rest guys I don't know but
it just says no win bonus that's
interesting and then Derek Lewis you
know following some hard times Dana said
he's not going to cut him because he
loves the guy but
you know we had Derek Lewis on uh below
the belt when I was doing the TV show he
came in there and that was like
right remember when he said he was done
he's retired and he was like I will I
was like what happened I thought he's
like get my back and [__] he's thinking
I can't stand losing I was God the
haters he's like no my kids come home my
kids are making fun of me man it sucks I
was like I get it and then I was he was
like so I was done then Dana called me
up and threw me this offer I couldn't
refuse and he's like I'm all right [__]
it
um let's do it so when I hear that like
if that's in there where you're fighting
for money even though he went on this
remarkable run
once the garden gets tough and the chips
are stacked against you and you don't
have that motivation to be the absolute
best in the world it this How It Ends
that's how it goes you know so uh big
personality outside doc John amazing
follow on social media but uh and he was
very upset at DC because DC was like I
think it's over for Derek Lewis you know
to be a top tier heavyweight
you know and it sucks guys hate whenever
you say this stuff but DC is right you
know it's tough man and for those
hardcores that stayed up all night for
this this what you stayed up for you get
your TKO you're like oh it's gonna be a
good night that woke me up and they have
a majority draw
a unanimous decision
a unanimous decision they're like all
right well it's Derek Lewis so there's
gonna be fireworks here and he gets
choked out in three minutes
tough night for the hardcores the
majority draw though if you saw the the
so do her choice Korean Superboy yeah
yeah and he was I I feel like he was not
easily winning but definitely winning
and then he got costed a point taken
away because he did the ref said he did
a headbutt he was just literally just
going like this slightly so he took a
point away took a point we cut the guy
really bad nothing it was literally just
kind of tapped but it was like he was in
a movement so it wasn't really so Dana
White gave him his uh win bonus oh
that's cool that's not true he did not
head butt him that's cool
yeah not that but you know the MVP of
that is no one who fought the MVP of
that is Laura senko yeah love uh senko
she crushed it man and she's there with
Bisping he's a Savage and and uh Brendan
you know they did the damn thing but
Laura Sanchez you're going to be peel
that card making history being the first
woman who absolutely deserves it you
guys know I don't [__] around with this
new woke thing where you know everyone's
the same no no but with Laura senko man
woman alien doesn't purple black white
Korean doesn't matter she is damn good
as an analyst everyone wants to take
things away from like oh it's just
because she's a hot girl in this current
climate no no Laura sanco would be your
analyst whether it was 1970 or 2023
that's how good she is at her job if
you've ever watched Dana White's
Contender series which is called Laura
senko's Contender series because she's
the star of that it should be her show
but she's been doing it for a hot second
just these newbies who probably don't
watch Tennis series like this chick this
chick is really good man woman alien
don't matter she's a Savage deserves to
be there so shout out to senko for doing
the damn thing a lot of pressure too you
know she may also mention that she had
to she was kind of looking at social
media which you know
and people are accusing her obviously
this is just you know just haters but
they're saying like oh she probably had
to sleep her way to get to that but
that's the that's insecurities of all
those losers uh on there because it's
like pretty girl so if and she also
she's clearly super attractive she could
be a model if she wanted to so you have
this ridiculously good-looking girl and
she happens to be in the fight business
which is majority male dominant right in
every aspect Fighters analysts people
that work in there the production the
fan base predominantly you know male
driven and they see this very attractive
girl I would assume 95 of the fan base
has never seen a girl like that or had a
conversation or sat down to have a drink
with so it's your it's your own
insecurities it's your way of trying to
take her down even though she's more
than qualified to do the job clearly she
crushed this so for them it's their way
of like oh I I bet you slept your way
it's like trying to you know it's a crab
mentality trying to take her down it's
like okay it's lame yeah just because
you never got the girl in high school it
doesn't mean you gotta spew hate towards
senko for God's sakes you know how I
know you're a loser you know it's like
come on dude what are you doing yeah she
crushed it and it's just a start for her
just the start she's gonna keep doing
the damn thing yeah uh but this isn't
about this isn't a full blunt uh Lauren
Sanko show we gotta get her back on food
truck though she was great yeah she was
awesome great
um this is about UFC 284 which if you
haven't heard we're doing a OG fight
Japan Joe Rogan this Saturday 9 p.m
Central Time 7 P.M Pacific Time Joe
Rogan's YouTube then we'll straight to
Spotify
um it's I can't remember last time I was
just decided for a fight
trying to think I don't like that the
magnitude of this fight this is what's
problem this is what is wrong with the
fight game right now is
don't get me wrong Conor and Michael
Chandler you guys know how balls deep
and Connor love Michael Chandler good
friend of mine
great fight uh Jon Jones coming back
great fight
there hasn't been a fight and I don't
know how long of a guy two guys two
gentlemen one at 45 who's a champ one at
55 who's champ who's a pound for pound
of one pound for pound number two
and they have two losses between the two
of them and they're dominant Fighters
that are putting that on the line and
fighting each other as far as skill set
goes talent and they're both in their
Prime I can't remember last time UC had
a fight of this magnitude that's gone
under the radar it just shows you where
the current kind of status of the sport
is at where
there's more news about Chandler and
Conor coaching on tough
and Alexander volkanasi fighting in the
main event in Australia
there's been more coverage that's what's
wrong with the sport there's been more
coverage
of the slap Fight League
of morons giving each other CT every
single time they slap each other like
some idiots and they have these guts and
they're in Under Armor there's been more
promotion for the slap Fight League
which isn't going well
then the two best fighters in multiple
divisions the pound for pound number one
versus pound for pound number two are
fighting in their Prime this is unheard
of it is a goddamn gift and nobody's
paying attention to it it's insane to me
insane insane
it's a phenomenal fight I don't know the
last time we've had this type of fight
and now I do think it's different
where when Izzy went up to 205
and he fought yawn you know I was a bit
of a nightmare
um I think Izzy's mentality thought he
could get it done but the just the sheer
size of yon played a huge Factor there
and he didn't entertain the stand up
there here you it's not that this isn't
the case you got a guy in Alexander
volcanovski Used to Be 210 pounds used
to fight at lightweight move down change
his diet became the most dominant uh you
know 145 or to ever do it but 55 isn't
that much of a stretch for him he he's
done it he's competed there before now a
while ago in different competition but
he can fight at 55. I think you're
getting a better version of okinafi at
55. again he's got an Islam who's the
Protege to khabib this guy is
some you know his coach who carries a
lot of weight says he's the best
lightweight to ever do it
versus the best 145 would ever do it
this fight is [__] nuts man nuts
and I'm gonna go out on a limit here get
my prediction
I don't like to disrespectfulness he's
getting I think you guys are forgetting
everyone keeps talking about the sheer
size of Islam and all this stuff
Alexander again his limbs his joints
everything he has a here's a two two
inch reach Advantage I actually think
his height his size is such an advantage
for him in this fight I think people are
gonna be surprised at how well local
office is going to do in this fight I
actually predict hot coming hot take I
think volcanopsy beats him via decision
I think volcanovski beats Mark Jeff via
decision I think
um
Mark Jeff is gonna get him down make no
mistake my Jeff's been wrestling since
he was in diapers against goats and
[__] werewolves and whatever the [__]
they're doing dagstan he didn't get him
down I don't think he's gonna be able to
control him down there I do think
volcanovski can get back to his feet
it's gonna be you know in Australia so
they're gonna be a little biased towards
volkanovsky I do think he beats him
um you know by one round I think he's
gonna be a close fight I think there's
gonna be some controversy I think Mark
Chev is going to take him down a lot of
people well way more uh and look more
into the takedowns opposed to what vocal
now she's doing on the feet so there's
gonna be rounds where I'm like well uh
Mike Jeff did get him down but
volcanovski's landed more shots on the
feet I think Mark Jeff's uh gonna
struggle with the tenacity with the
speed the quickness the the sheer lack
of height with uh volkonovsky and I
think volcanovski is gonna be able to
get back to his feet frustrate makachev
and win the rounds just by staying
outside guide I think you will see kicks
I think his speed his quickness his
overall up and down game is going to be
the deciding factor there I I think
volcanovski beats him via decision and I
know I should be sold on machev I
realize how [__] Talent he is I real
uh realize how great he is at 55 I just
don't like this particular matchup for
microchip I think he loses your decision
I think the they fight multiple times
this isn't the last time we're going to
get this fight then volcanovski if
anybody can do it at 45 he's so dominant
at 55 there's a lot of good fights for
him Mark Chev is definitely the toughest
fight for him at 55 but I think it's the
perfect matchup for him I think he gets
it done and he's a plus 310 so this is a
big take he's up plus 310.
which is massive sport especially for
pound for pound greatness I just the
lack of uh respect for volcanovsky the
difference is whenever there's these
super fights right
you know when Tj going down to 25 which
was insane when uh Connor would bounce
up
um the difference in Connor has this
similar trait which is why he was
successful at 45-55
even though he didn't defend that 55 but
the difference is the similar between
volkanovski and uh Conor McGregor when
you go for these double status Champs is
they believe they can do it volkanovsky
trust me 100 thinks he can beat mock
Jeff thinks that muchev uh although he
is bigger isn't stronger and voconazio
wins on food truck was talking about he
doesn't train with guys at 45 he's too
strong he only trains with guys at 70
and higher so I know Mike Chev he's been
arrested since he's been in diapers and
his judo's ridiculous and khabibi this
is how confident that's why that's why I
don't like this why slowly up for the
past week I've been decided how I'm
gonna break this down at who I'm gonna
go with I don't like what I'm hearing
from microchip's Team even khabib even
though he's not giving me his corner
months ago inside the Octagon gave it or
did the interview giving away the game
plan that's how confident they are they
go mock Jeff volkanov's getting worked
on his wrestling doesn't matter we've
been doing it for 20 years vocalypse
can't make up the time so we're gonna
give him the clinch wear them out get
them tired take him down submit them
okay
that's all confident they're giving away
the game plan now it's not like it's
this oh my God come to Jesus mom like
Mike Jeff's gonna give him the clinch
and grapple no we know I'm just saying I
I really think the the lack of respect
for microchip's team towards volkanovski
is going to bind him in the ass and by
the third round you're gonna see my
chest my holy [__] this is a much more
uh tougher fight than we thought it was
going to be now we're getting them down
you're not taking down five times around
but we're getting them down we can't
hold him down he's getting out of it now
there's a chance because volkanovsky his
scrambles he's tough on the ground we've
seen him with Brian Ortega he gets in
trouble he gets out of it his is the way
he can create those scrambles
is ridiculous high level the problem is
when you're creating scrambles you leave
certain things open your neck your back
and arm you know a ligament so
I do think volcanocity has to be careful
in transition from the ground to his
feet because Mark Jeffrey gets your back
in your neck's open he's gonna take
advantage of it so they're the only way
I see this being a finish is my chef
does get a hold of his neck which could
happen in those transitions but I I
think volvonovsky's prepared for that I
think he's been training for that I
think volcanovski beats him to be
controversial because our fan base the
MMA fan base is to be so tuned in on
takedowns takedowns takedowns you know
so I I really think that vocalypse
you're gonna look at the copy strike
numbers but you're everyone's gonna be
like what about the takedown supposed to
be more about the Striking and I'll take
vocal Nazi striking all day over mock
Jeffs
I think he has the tools to do it I
think pound for pound skill wise I think
he's better
um I think his gas tank especially at 55
is going to be a problem I think speed
his quickness again his tenacity and the
number one thing is that Kobe mentality
Alexander volkanovsky 100
deep down in every fiber in his body
thinks he's gonna win this fight and
that is a big deal I think volcanovsky
wins via decision be controversial
because all you guys are gonna care
about is these takedowns even though
he's not doing anything with them but
when I've seen him back to his feet
continue to Peppers dagestanian face
continue to light up that hairy [__]
left leg of his or his South Pole right
leg of his that inside kick is very
tricky very hard to deal with tough to
time the takedown's there I think
vognostic wins via decision and you're
gonna get this fight I bet you get it
three times just because here's the
thing both nasty is a good matchup for
my for volkanovski you know is a huge
threat to Mike Jeff but outside that
there's not a lot of threats from OCTA
55 he's going to dominate 50 55
eventually go to 70. but volkonovsky is
going to get it done and then outside
that mock Jeff's Gonna Keep winning so
you can get this fight a few more times
that's what's going to happen
and I I do think volcanovski goes down
as your pound-for-pound grace never do
it
now I'll always have Jon Jones there
especially if John wins uh March 4th
March 4th right a few wins March 4th at
UFC uh uh 285 that catapults him no
doubt no ends at butts about it he's
you're pounding one of all time
especially at heavyweight
um yeah March 4th in Vegas but uh I I do
think this uh
when it's all said and done volcanovski
is going to be your pound for pound
number one of all time
now I always sway I'm biased towards the
heavyweights and light heavy weights the
heavier divisions who are so dominant
because there's less room for air but
for vocalypse if he can beat box Chev
there's no doubt about it he's number
one
and then there's still the co-main event
it's a great card man and we're doing
campaign for it I can't [__] wait
yeah Rodriguez Josh Emmett phenomenal
fight I think Josh Abbott gets it done I
think he's on a dog too I always I
always take the dogs
I always take the dogs man Josh Emmett's
plus 140. I think he gets it done
I think he's just too tough for your for
Yaya Rodriguez I'm excited for uh Jack
against Randy Brown I think he gets it
done Justin tafa Parker Porter Parker
Peter Porter right so best name in
Combat Sports right now
uh that fights whatever but Jimmy crew
Alonzo Benfield what they're trying to
do is come out the gates hot they're
trying to get finishes with this light
heavyweight heavyweight and welterweight
fight they're trying to get three
finishes quick so this main card is fire
for pay-per-view buys
uh and then they end the prelims the
main event on the prelims are boy Tyson
Pedro who I'm always rooting for and
they kick it off with uh Jamie Malarkey
who's fantastic to watch he needs to get
it done fighting his backyard so if
you're an Aussie fan I think it's gonna
be a great night for you guys you guys
can go ahead and start celebrating
volcanovsky's win Josh Emma's not your
guy but whatever Jackson get it done
um tafa probably gets it done Jimmy crew
gets it done Tyson Pedro gets it done
Malarkey gets it done they're going to
be chewy all the way to the [__]
Sunset I think come Saturday
come Sunday morning
so it's gonna be interesting man but I
can't wait for this let's take another
little break here I can't wait for UFC
284 and I will be doing a fight campaign
with Joe Rogan on JRE YouTube which will
then go to Spotify but if you're
watching that companion you're like man
job is on one look at the way his brain
is firing off these crazy words his
vocabulary got so much better well I'm
here to tell you I'm going to be a
little inside secret here I'm on Kratom
but not just any Kratom the only crate
of my trust I'm talking about happy
hippo I'm on it right now I use their
little Cherry shot they have a highly
concentrated Kratom Cherry shot or use
the pink lemonade or the butterscotch is
my favorite right now however you want
to try your Kratom out whether it's
gummies powder concentrated shots like I
take they all work but they're only
going to work if you use happy hippo you
can't trust any Kratom out there happy
hippo has the best Kratom on planet
Earth you got a happyhippo.com promo
code is thick23 thick with three C's
t-h-i-c-c-c 23 you save 20 off the best
Kratom on the freaking planet I use it
every single time I need to be in front
of a camera or on a mic I rely on Kratom
but I only rely on one Kratom and that's
Happy Hippo happyhippo.com promo code is
thick 23 20 off use as many times as you
want let's get back to the program
happyhippo.com promo code thick23. good
good news fam my friends at manscape now
sells beard products my beard looks like
trash it looks like the printer ran out
of ink but I'm still here aren't I but
for those of you with that just just
manly 300 Spartan beard man do they have
some products for you they're once again
doing their thing in Men's Grooming with
the brand new beard hedger Pro kit from
a beer trim to a fresh shave the
technology behind the beard hedger Pro
kit allows you to shape your signature
beard just how you want man now you can
finally use manscape products to make
your drapes match your carpet by going
to manscape.com use the promo code shop
for toybersoft and free shipping the
best beard products on the market just
when you didn't think manscape could get
any better oh but they just specialize
in my Jewels downstairs nope they going
upstairs I'm upstairs that's my friend
Theo would say no one likes a weird
beard so say goodbye to all your stubble
trouble with manscape Pro's beard kit
alright it all starts with the beard
hedger this thing is a jug or not of
fixing faces your girl don't like your
beard you well now when this thing gets
a hold of it first off this cordless
trimmer has a freaking supersonic wheel
that gives you 20 hair cutting lengths
all with one guard what do you want to
do on Philly fade on your face you wanna
you want that freaking Spartan beard we
got you man it's waterproof you can do
it in the shower but probably do in
front of the mirror just not to mess
stuff up the titanium coated t-blade is
tough on the hair but smooth on your
face all right single stroke they got
you bro we don't need multiple Strokes
one stroke hitter here first there's a
beer shampoo and conditioner all right
and guess what else manscape has a
little beard oil for you that's right
it's essential piece for your main
facial accessory no one wants a guy
who's beard is brittle and dry and
smells like hummus all right cap off the
kit with the beard balm a Pomade that
shapes dude shape your stuff up I can't
do it my Beard's awful but still I have
psoriasis but if you don't have
psoriasis and you have a beard
get this all right so we get 20 stop and
free shipping with the code shop at
manscape.com that's 20 off with the free
shipping at manscape.com use the code
shop all right manscape beard hedger one
stroke one guard 20 length get your
beard on manscaped all right Tim what do
you got let me look at Parker Porter
front he reminds me of something Peter
Parker Porter
okay anyways
um yeah so we did talk about the
Chandler and McGregor thing but how do
you feel about them doing tough
uh tough needs you know that Lifeline it
needs a little
life into that series I like the idea
that it's not just on ESPN plus it's on
regular span 2 which is massive I think
this can go well
um I'm curious to see the demand of
Conor right now I'll watch it and that's
Connor he's probably the only guy to get
me to watch that show so I see what the
UFC's doing there I agree with UFC doing
Chandler and uh Connor over uh Connor
and Ferguson for a variety of reasons
um and this fight is at 170 which I love
so
um the question is what version of Conor
are we gonna get I don't know but he's
gonna be forced not to be on Yachts not
to be playing grab ass not to be in his
Gucci silk
you know robe and all that [__] on a
yacht because he's gonna be in fight
camp with these guys on The Ultimate
Fighter so it's a perfect situation for
the UFC brilliant what they're doing
there yeah and uh apparently as of now
he still hasn't re-entered usada's
testing pool so yeah you guys need to
get off this it's not happening it's
Conor McGregor shut the [__] up you know
things not happening drug test and all
this stuff don't matter he's an outlier
okay he's the one exception they are
saying that he would have to do six
months and then get two negative tests
sure sure later this year [__] okay
uh this is just a funny post from Tough
All My Children Edition hilarious lesson
for you now you're batshit crazy if you
think Connor Chandler is gonna beat the
numbers The Ultimate Fighter 10 did
with Kimbo Slice yeah Brandon John yeah
all right Roy Nelson
all right that was a pretty dope season
though the best yeah the ratings say the
best what can I do I'm so new with it
this is from the fight Mafia I don't
know how accurate this is but it was
interesting for me to see these these
pay-per-view cells Conor versus Anthony
Joshua
so it says Connor's 18.4 million total
yeah in nine pay-per-view events
yeah 13 paper events for Joshua and
that's thirteen four it's just different
because McGregor those nine pay-per-view
events were massive massive and then
with uh Joshua some of those 13 weren't
as massive that's true because the cards
like stacked yes versus just Joshua
representing okay but those counter
fights were massive and stacked
all right um this is algerman Sterling
saying that he is 100 fighting Henry
suudo in May that's he needs a little
bit more time past April uh-huh and then
he might go up to 145 after that yeah I
love him at 45 and I agree with him if
he were able to beat uh sahudo
he still needs to clear out the division
so if he were to beat sahuto which is a
big F but if he beats sehudo you still
got sugar there if sugar eats a fight uh
you know you got Cheeto so there's some
other tough test for him there I don't
think I don't think now is the time to
jump there I think there's some massive
fights for him still at 35 but uh I like
it
you mentioned Cheeto so originally
Cheeto versus San Higgin was going to be
at the Apex but I guess fans are going
crazy because they want to see him in a
big you know venue so they actually
moved it to a bigger Venue 10 000 fans
there in San Antonio yep
that's such a good fight yeah I can't
wait for that fight what else you got
Jim I do a fight campaign for that uh
Cheeto fight she was our boy he said
Mark send Hagen's my boy too you know
I'm not picking that fight yeah uh not
this one local let's go jump through
this one I think we talked about this
let's call it Arnold Allen gets my dick
they're headlining oh he was a Fight
Night fantastic fight
even though it's free well kind of you
still have to have ESPN but yeah that's
a phenomenal fight this will fight too
it's not like Max always it's like
gatekeeper this is just a big big fight
much well deserved for Arnold Allen like
you're fighting a legend it's a legend
who's not over the hill like Arnold
beats him we're going Sizzler
and who do you think I think you're
gonna pick Arnold right uh
um I don't know I do not know I do nice
try I know so you got Max
I think honestly I love Max but I think
Arnold gets it yeah Savage
probably the best Prospect out of
England since Tom aspinall for sure
Tommy aspinal
um so Cody's original opponent Julio RC
is out due to a knee injury and then
he's gonna get a guy named Trevin Jones
for UFC 285 and then I looked at Cody
Cody's record so it's not exactly he's
lost uh what five out of six but his
opponent the new opponent also not doing
that amazing so it's probably a better
matchup
he's losing uh decision decision
technical submission tkl submission
submission
decision yeah I think Gary's about to
piece this dude
um all right so this is a Jake Paul and
Tommy Fury and his wife so I guess they
gave birth right and then they didn't
announce it gave birth yeah yeah that a
baby and then uh I guess they didn't
even know she gave birth to a human
being
they both did they did and um so they
didn't they didn't publicly announce it
and then somehow Jake Paul got that info
and then he wrote hold on a second here
these are these young kids man I'm
telling you aren't they they have no
feel they have no control they have no
filter
there's no line they won't cross they're
such Savages oh there he goes somebody
has no excuses now a baby's born money's
massive immigration no issue Tyson
promises he and papa will make Tommy
retire from boxing and change his last
name if you can't beat the YouTuber
tomorrow I'm coming to London to look at
all three Furies and I and Shake on that
promise people are mad at that yeah
because they didn't get to announce
themselves somehow okay got the
information yeah that's [__] up and
then that's what this is what these
young kids do man vaping sucking [__]
getting tattoos on their face and [__]
and apparently
when this picture came out with Tommy
Fury and his Molly and his baby Jake
Paul wrote
why do I keep losing this thing right
there
no no not that oh that's right there I
know dude
I know uh just in time to watch your dad
get knocked out yeah
uh this one put Molly May Trout from
Manchester to London just to give birth
whilst keeping her privacy one of her
basic human rights and Jake Paul took
her announcement yeah it's [__] up but
all is fair in Love and War these kids
do they both Love and War these kids
these these youngsters they grow up
watching Euphoria they lost all their
Foundation of what's right what's wrong
you know I grew up on Saved By The
Belmont a different time
much different time
um I guess
I forgot where this was at but Kevin Lee
recently took a picture with Dana White
and then he posted this as well
hold on make Mania is he there for a
slight slap Fight League oh it's gone
now
but uh yeah so people are saying because
you know he was part of Eagle FC
khabib's yeah which is done I think
right
man [__] this I have all the money in
the world I should have a Toyota Tundra
I'm gonna ride off in the sunset in
Pakistan
yeah
uh anyway so that's just like
um in the slap bite League that would be
terrible hopefully he's back in the UFC
but yeah that'd be terrible all right so
this is Conor McGregor offering to
sponsor Katie Taylor if she gets her
fight her dream fight in crook Park and
he would said he would pay up to like
500k wow yeah that'd be great
kind of doing the Lord's work yes he is
the extra security bill is 500k to have
Katie Taylor fight at crook Park a
responsive event to see this happen wow
and Aaron said let's talk dog dog
bet they make it happen
and this is you mentioned this before
Sean O'Malley doesn't have a manager or
anyone that takes care of his did he
just negotiate he negotiated one huh but
now he's not but now he's number one in
the world so he renegotiated so UFC Dana
White uh announced signed an eight fight
extension was at 16 fights O'Malley
addressed the New Deal on his project
has gone a very great contract I'm proud
of I didn't know that I'm very happy
with I truly don't think any manager uh
that I had could have went in there and
got me what I got that also helps with
the relationship built with UFC I feel
like I've earned this contract I feel
like I've earned them out that I'm
getting paid yeah all on his own this
next fight
well he says he's happy yeah good for
him so we mentioned power slot slap
fighting earlier so remember it was like
the original when it came out it wasn't
great it was pretty good decent and now
it's like dropping even Laura yeah keep
going that way it doesn't go like it
doesn't go like this it's gonna go here
and
and this is what Dana White says JFK Jr
airplane the popularity of slot fighting
on digital media like internet tick tock
here's the thing ball bent Dana White
claims his new power slab leak is
outperforming the WWE and UFC NFL on
Tick Tock yeah because it's a [__] show
yeah because we're all making fun of it
yeah we we like to see just the
highlight of someone getting knocked
unconscious from a slap but that's not
where you make your body when you make
somebody off Tick Tock but the top
performance people repo saying how
stupid this looks
it's not because people have more
respect for people who care more about
your slap tightly compared to the WWE or
UFC or NFL and here's the thing
the only reason we're aware of is
because you're using the UFC platform to
put it in our face in our faces like a
dick we don't want it in our mouth
it's like he's just [__] no no all
right all right you know just this dick
in your mouth
it's still not working yeah I scroll
past it I don't want to see it
uh but this is interesting kind of
disappointing too Anthony Smith
he went on record saying how much he
loves it can't wait for it can't wait
for a pay-per-view of slap fighting
and of course Nate Diaz I'll show you
keep that Analyst job I know people you
got to do what you got to do right
here's I'm kind of with Anthony Smith on
this it is interesting now I'm not
tuning into it every Wednesday but the
highlights like Dana saying it's bigger
than UFC WWE also how you can [__] on
the FC it's even bigger than UFC it's
like hey dude
couldn't quit Force us to think this was
a good business decision it's not take
it out dude just take the owl it's all
good baby you still got 400 in the bank
take the hell you know it was stupid as
[__]
it's so stupid it's so stupid uh he told
MMA I'm serious I've been saying it for
[__] months I cannot get enough of
the power slap league so do it
so you don't participate in it uh my
body is ready for a pay-per-view my body
is ready yeah that was weird too I will
pay for it I don't care how much it
costs I'll prepay I'll prepay the next
10 I love it I don't know why I can't
give you a reason uh Lionheart thinks
this uh love for the snap fight maybe
down to the fact you have to speak with
some of the power slap contestants and
watch them film The Show
maybe because I was there during the
pilot of it and I've seen it in person I
get to meet these guys I gotta talk to
them I imagine you think some of these
guys would be like that are involved in
the power slap Fight League and then he
finishes off here I think about what
kind of person would do it that's
exactly how they are I'm a fan of the of
chaos these guys are goddamn Maniacs
there's something wrong with them
something not right they've got a couple
screws loose and they're my type of
people I love them I loved every second
I love talking to them support them I
know a lot of people hate it I know a
lot of people think it's gross I love
Combat Sports not sport I don't even uh
know if I call it sport there you go it
might not be but I love it there you go
no one they say it
it's so funny dude
so post seven big Deal's response about
response to it goes Anthony Smith is a
dumb [__]
it's so funny I I don't think you're
dumb if you like the slap Fight League I
I maybe if Dana White was involved and
it you know maybe I'd be more it's so it
just it's just uh
it's a cheap view that's all this is
yeah I mean listen World Star videos of
two women fighting and their tits coming
out probably get more views than the UFC
World Stars might be like yo we're
bigger and more mainstream than the UFC
so if that's your annual we're bigger
than UFC which you're part of and built
which is so hilarious this slap Fight
League which is [__] stupid is bigger
than the UFC NFL and [__] NBA on Tick
Tock like that's your angle that's when
those words came out of his mouth you
should be like [__] because worldstar's
doing yeah yeah when we show people
getting shot in the face it beats UFC
numbers too doesn't mean it's more
popular just mean people are turning
like let me see this let me see this
complete train wreck that's not gonna be
around long
yeah the fact that it's tied to the UFC
is what really bothers me the most me
too yeah me too that's what drives me
nuts I'm with Anthony Smith it's there's
something about I've said this book I
think I said before you're one of the
I'm one of the few who watch it too I
don't know it's because just because
it's such a train wreck you're like I
can't believe and and I know it's not
gonna be around too long I have to watch
it I just enjoy it last year yeah all
right last one this is uh we spoke off
uh spoke about this off air but so Dana
White forgot Islam makachev's name when
he was promoting this was very Biden of
him
wasn't it it was very weird I mean
honestly I forget I'm sure you forget
sometimes even famous people just forget
on the Fly sometimes absolutely this
won't be tough absolutely not especially
if I own the that'd be like me for
getting one of your guys's names
if someone's like uh who's the producer
on show I'm like that
you say it that way okay yeah you know
it's your business I know and you're in
charge of promoting and you're at a
Prescott I would at least looked over
the Sheep like all right what are they
gonna ask you know and it's a week out
like come on dude and you're getting
[__] for not promoting it that's the
that's where this is even crazier
because makachev even was he was telling
me before like I don't like how they're
not even yeah man and then it's his name
and the fights is this fight is not
talent wise it's [__] stupid best
fight the UFC's had and I don't know how
long competitive wise nuts the most too
talented guys on the roster fighting
each other in their Prime
and you want to talk about power Fight
League I I think this is a sign where
Dana's literally he's over it he's over
the UFC
he's over the UFC that is no longer his
baby anymore the power slap Fight League
is his main focus this is more evident
than ever forgets the name of makachav
the week before the big the huge fight
which they haven't promoted he's been
telling the UFC brass to promote the
power supply League more because
hopefully gets better numbers on
tick tock
if you don't think he's over the UFC and
has lost passion you're out of your
[__] mind because if you were still
balls deep in the FC and you want to
take it to different levels and he
weren't just riding off the coaches of
ESPN knowing you can get your check no
matter what you would be doing the
Lord's work trying to promote this fight
of the two most talented most skilled
Fighters you've ever had compete in
their Prime instead you're more focused
on the power slap Fight League you can't
tell me he's still
passionate about the UFC you can't I
can't we've been seeing more power slap
stuff than the UFC 285 sure for sure
also if you're so Pastor about the FC
and you want to grow it more why would
you even
get into this power slap fight [__]
out of nowhere how many you it can't be
a money thing it's literally a passion
and this here's the thing there's
nothing wrong with that I've been down
you know I don't be too into the weeks
here I've been that way on some shows
where I'm like I've been doing for five
years I want to do something else new
over here yeah I've lost passion for
doing that show
I'd rather focus on this over here
there's nothing wrong with that
everything has a timeline everything has
a time limit for Dana just he's bored as
[__] look at his face there
he's on
Dana White these press conferences look
like Ben Affleck at the Grammys I hope
you saw that he looked miserable next to
JLo I don't know if they just got a
fight or whatever the whole time just
like staring at the ceiling
play this for me
when you have the number one versus
number two pound-for-pound guy guys in
the world fighting each other like you
said in their prime it never it's never
happened if you think of all the fights
that we've done in the UFC so um you
know when you talk about Legacy if
vulcanovski could pull this off it's
obviously massive
of course
um and if uh if
um checked out
um
yeah you can pull it off it's um you
know he's on his way to building an
incredible Legacy yeah yeah you forget
the guy's name in the main event I mean
I'm sure he's super tired of promoting
slap League too
but I guess I get you yeah he's just
it's a passion thing uh here's what I'm
not knocking for it but just start its
own thing and focus on that and then
have someone run the UFC account that's
promoting makachev voknowsky for God's
sakes
don't do us like that Daddy don't and
also don't disrespect volkanasia makshev
they're never gonna forget this either
of all people magachev who was
criticizing the promotion and then he
forgets his name
yeah pretty bad he's like you don't have
an argument
I'm sorry what's your name
but do you see Dave Smith at slap Fight
League the other night Dave Smith on
tick tock
insane well
uh let's give this thing a promo that
Dana should have uh you have the two
most skilled fighters on the roster in
their Prime
they have two losses between the two of
them they have probably over 50 wins
between the two of them over 50 wins two
losses the two most skilled fighters in
the UFC in their Prime are fighting this
Saturday in the main event for the pound
for pound title
if that doesn't get your nut sacked
ramped up nothing well in this sport
it is the two best doing it fighting in
their prime one guy is under size but
he's [__] dominant has more skill
than anybody else on the roster the
other guy is of dagestani royalty he was
raised and coached by khabib
nakamurdov's dad for this exact moment
they're both fighting for Pure UFC
Legacy the winner of this fight is hands
down the most
talented best fighter on the UFC roster
and they're fighting for that this
Saturday in the main event
what
and you forgot the guy's name
grow up so you got uh islamachev
Alexander voknowsky fighting for
straight up history this Saturday on
pay-per-view in volkanovski's backyard
Rodriguez Joshua Midfield and they got
Jack Della versus Randy Brown got uh
Jimmy crew Alonzo meningfield yup my boy
Tyson Pedro fighting you have Jamie
Malarkey the most Australian name ever
they're all fighting this [__]
Saturday
I don't know if it's new better than
Tick Tock numbers I don't give a flying
[__] I'm 39 years old but what I do give
a [__] about is the two most talented
gentlemen on the UFC roster who are good
at every aspect of mixed martial arts
and have one loss each and over 50 wins
combined are fighting this [__]
Saturday at 9 00 PM central time and I'm
doing a fight campaign with Joe Rogan
Eddie Bravo Brian Callan if that doesn't
get your dick throbbing nothing around
this Sport and I feel sorry for you go
watch power Fight League All right so
that's going down make sure you tune
into the fight companion make sure you
support islamachev Alexander volkanovsky
yeah Rodriguez Josh Emmett all right
it's gonna be a fun one I can't wait
best fight in a hot second show some
respect tune in buy the pay-per-view
that's this Saturday 9 00 p.m Central
Time 7 P.M Pacific time
um that's it uh tour date wise shot to
Springfield Missouri my favorite place
of all time top five but next up is
Naples Florida I'll be doing fishing out
there
uh watching fish by day
stand-up comedy by Night February 16th
through the 18th Naples Florida
Bakersfield one night only February 23rd
that thing's almost sold out can't add
show so get your tickets right now Brea
California one night two shows early
show Late Show Brea California March 4th
is Cowboys fight campaign with some very
special guests Rampage Jackson jelly
roll and we got another very special
guest coming up too which I'll announce
soon all right so that is March 4th on
thick boy YouTube they have Oklahoma
City March 9th March 9th through 11th
Tacoma Washington March 23rd through
25th get your tickets right now but
Naples I will see you guys soon uh that
is next week February 16th through 18th
tune in to UFC 284 mock Joe volkanasi go
down this Trucking Saturday also tune
into uh Joe Rogan's YouTube uh if you
can watch the fight live on there and it
jumps on over to Spotify after that so I
love you guys enjoy the fights be nice
each other stay safe till next time I'm
out
boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding